there's nothing you can i have to take a
[ __ ] really to be honest with you right
now
because i ate this frog so i want to go
in the bathroom right there so you guys
continue and then i'll come
we do mma minute while he's gone yeah if
we have anything to talk about there's a
fight which fight wonder boy oh
boring wait wait wait who's fighting
when is that what is that when what
happens yeah you're not going to be here
saturday you have to poop also
saturday yeah that's your boy rory and
you go baby but rory is also my boy
though
i love him i have thoughts on all this
are you pooping
yeah i'm gonna go poop but hold on real
quick okay yeah i can still watch
saturday though on my ipad it depends
where you are i don't know what these
restrictions are
i have to go to north carolina that's
where trump is
can i just say i went to school there
and uh my roommate had a confederate
flag and i had to sleep back to that all
the time
see that's what i'm saying i was only
asian there all right let's take a [ __ ]
go ahead
all right so quick mma minute with
kalila
coco so we have the fight this weekend
uh to fight night
we have rory mcdonald the red king or
whatever
[ __ ] name he is against steven
wonderboy
thompson who now fights with uh ray
longo fight team
so with chris weidman all them he trains
with him oh in new york in new york he
trains there now
so what are your thoughts on that
because that's a crazy fight
cause rory is not somebody who makes
very many mistakes either
he's not i mean he's very calculated
he's very careful he's not somebody
who would get baited in by
um wonder boy his setups but here's the
thing who do you
want to win the fight that's the hard
thing they're two likeable guys and
i personally in terms of just god
i i i'm okay with wonder boy
having a loss at this point in his
career
i think it's time for rory to really
to just really take it i've always been
a huge fan of his i know he's a little
bit more of the quiet
a silent assassin type murderer yeah but
he seems like such a super smart like
book nerd and i really like rory
he's almost like a george kimmel a
fighting in george kimmel very strategic
good job george
uh here's my thing with wonderboy i have
to go for him because karate style i
love that he's older now he's 32.
yeah he had a little feeling like if he
loses this and he loses another one it's
like
he's out of reach and he's a fun fighter
it's out
the only reason it's not out of reach
for him because not only was he uh
a late bloomer but he hasn't gotten hit
a lot
he has i think that his career can exist
for a long time and we're seeing now
that i mean in the in the age of hgh
like you can
prolong your career as long as you don't
get
hit often you know i if if he was a guy
who's
who has sustained you know some you know
legitimate knockouts
in the course of his career i'd be
worried i'd be like yeah you know he
probably just has you know a few more
years left in him but
yeah he's had a late start but i think
he can have at least another good 10
years you know you're right he does move
around a lot
yeah but i i i love wonder boy i think
he's isn't he from north carolina yeah
he's south carolina oh south carolina
what he's gonna show up at bobby's show
yeah he's a perfect example of what
seems that
we were just talking about earlier just
like a good christian boy very good
christian the philippians love him
because of his
oh yeah that's right yeah and he he
probably has some pretty conservative
ideas but he's probably somebody that i
could get on with you know
and here's the thing about rory he's
also fighting out his contract
so he's probably super motivated and i
want him
also to win because just like you i
think the fighters
should get the max money they deserve so
if he loses this
uh he doesn't have that leverage anymore
with ufc to get a
big contract right because gosh but he's
had some i mean his last
loss was yeah i know greatest fight of
the century what i'm saying that was not
a loss
to me i never i looked at him and i
thought yeah
both both of those guys are winners
there's no way anyone watching that
fight thought otherwise
that was such a great fight and how do
you feel about the
other fight donald cerrone at 170
against
patrick cote i'm gonna go with sironi
yeah patrick cuts a very cute boy and
you're going to say that what's up why
can't i just say that i'm sorry he's top
ten five hot mma fighters
oh thank you god
uh rory all right um patrick latest one
of them
okay keep going oh god we're not going
to do mma minute and just rate hot guys
it's very long let's keep going you're
going to be shocked
keep going what do you have [ __ ] roy
nelson brock lesnar
okay you like big dick [ __ ]
don't you
rory nelson's butt cheeks uh i love roy
nelson's in my
it's in my um um what do you call it
radar i find him totes cute
i don't i feel like i love his belly
heart attack at any second
no that guy when they have their um
weight distributed like that i think
they live a little bit longer
what what girl ever says that what i
love it when this guy has his weight
distributed like that
i like centralized fat i like apple
shaved bodies
uh please send your pictures of your
body if you're apple shaped kalila get
her please do
are you kidding me i love fat guys and
it's really weird that i
say this how many fat guys have you
dated us uh probably at least
not counting four like slept with or
just dated slept with
oh a good amount i don't mind that
jiggle
i am not against but the only thing that
i find to be an issue eventually if it
turns into a relationship
is just eating habits that dif that
differ from mine i like the appearance
i just don't like the lifestyle that
goes with the with goes into looking
like that
so if you can just be a fat healthy guy
like fat joe
or like dj khaled you know because i
always see him
if you can just like um if you're just
heavyset and that's just your genetics
and you have
you know you know a nice little rotund
appearance i'm so okay with that
as a matter of fact that turns me on
interesting i'm really anti-six-pack
these days
anti-six-pack yeah i am if it if you
naturally have it because you're just a
fit guy but if you're just
oh you can tell like okay do you watch
the bachelorette no none of you guys do
you never know
george like yes we do all the time okay
just find this guy there's a guy on
there his name is
chad and i'm sure no way his name is
chad right
this is i i know a lot of i know a lot
of women who probably just
think that he is the adonis the epitome
of
attractive but when i look at his body
and i see his
appearance he he looks like he would
smell like
protein shakes and farts uh true and
also probably on steroids you can't have
this
[ __ ] veins on your chest bro heroid
rages on the show
jesus he does legit roid rages on the
show and get
gets kicked off but what i'm saying is
when i look at a guy that chiseled
i think that he has i associate it with
a certain smell
and that smell of whey protein and
rancid farts
that's all his genes will smell like oh
my god
but you the thing is you've been with
guys like that
uh i've just the rainbow baby i've been
with it all
and i'm proud of the fat boys i've been
with but really quick number one
hottest mma fighter male alan gerbain
versace oh he's so not what i like he's
too pretty
all right uh bobby do you have a uh a
pick for the uh roy mcdonald
uh wonderboy thompson fight
hold on a second what the rory fight
dealing with something right now
oh okay seriously are we still gonna go
on with this in the middle of a podcast
uh well one more fight then uh valerie
turner
where's johann alderwood oh my god
you know i really like joanne calderwood
i liked her a lot in the show she's
really like soft talking have you heard
her speak
yeah she speaks like this but she's a
great boxer it's very good
i think that valerie letourneau is
probably going through some um
a psychological or some heartbreak after
watching her man get
by dan henderson but uh i think valerie
is going to take it because i think that
she's
you saw the way she fought against
joanna she was amazing yeah she killed
her
yeah and then a favorite fighter of you
guys a random marcos is fighting i like
random marcos a lot the girl from
iran from she's iraqi iraq's are you
[Music]
yeah
you